where will you go when you die
what are you doing with the life that
you have been given
demons are real
do you believe aliens exist
over 4 000 years ago there was a flood
we now have more evidence than ever
knowing this truth will change your life
forever all the answers are found in
scripture in the Bible
hey guys you know that at the end of my
videos I always say life is short so
don't waste yours I say it you hear it
but the day I want it to sink in because
your life can disappear at any moment
you're about a vapor one day you're here
and the next you are gone
and some of you men watching this video
right now might not even be here next
year
my two brothers they died in their early
20s they thought that they would
probably die at 60 70 80 years old
what are most of us doing with our lives
these days men are becoming worse and
man I'm even ashamed
to even talk about my own Afrikaans
culture
for what we have become
men drinking themselves into a pulp
using the most vulgar words in front of
innocent little children arrogant
boastful men living fully for the world
in all its Darkness
and then where will you go when you die
choosing to live for the best of this
Darkness this world what it can offer
you and then
at the end just after a few years
you die and you lose your soul for all
eternity
so let me ask you what are you doing
with the life that you have been given
what are you doing with your life
it's not a trick question I'm seriously
asking you to think about it more
importantly are you using the time
you've been given to prepare for the
life that is to come after this short
temporary world
to help you answer these questions I'm
going to give you 10 Deep truths that
every man should know some of them might
be shocking to you to those of you who's
been here on my channel for a while
because I've not really spoken about
this on this channel ever
and it is going to be shocking to the
Core
but it is time to open up your eyes to
the truth
so in this moment I want you to stop
stop the rat race that you're in all
your thoughts and things going on in the
world just stop
and for once
just really sit down
and focus on what I'm going to say to
you and think about your life seriously
let's start with the first one let's
talk about the importance of Truth
find truth keep truth and live truth we
all come into this world the same way
through our mothers right then we try to
make sense of the world and we make
decisions based on the information we
have the little we do know
but what if some of what you think
is a lie made up by others to try and
control the way that you think
to kind of tell you what you need to
believe without you even realizing it
there's a quote that says there are two
ways to be fooled one is to believe what
is not true and the second is to refuse
to believe what is true
now finding truth is one thing but
keeping it and living by that truth is
another thing and a lot of people
struggle with it they they struggle to
accept truth so they ignore it
instead they live in a made-up fantasy
world and that is psychologically
extremely unhealthy
for example a man who just found out he
has a psychological disorder and don't
want to accept it like someone who has
bipolar but doesn't accept it he won't
drink his pills which will cause him to
fall into an episode that will hurt a
lot of people including himself another
example is someone who deep down knows
that God is real they exists but he
doesn't want to accept it because then
he knows he's got to live righteously
and he doesn't want to so he chooses to
lie to himself and says God does not
exist to give himself a free ticket to
sin to lie cheat steal and maybe even
murder
you know then it is strange that this
type of person the same person will then
blame God for all the wrong that is in
the world while this person is actually
part of the cause
creating more pain and suffering in the
world because he lies because he cheats
because he steals and murders
so he blames God but he says that God
does not exist
the thing is with the truth is
truth is truth you cannot change the
truth
yeah you can change your perception of
the truth but you cannot change the
truth a lot of people these days says no
this is my truth this is his truth this
is her truth and no it's not
it's your perception of the truth for
example if you're a girlfriend or wife
cheats on you and you find out you can
tell yourself it never happened and even
deceive yourself to believe it but it
won't change the truth the fact is that
she did cheat on you
you see you cannot run away from the
truth truth is truth and the quicker you
accept all truth
the better life you will have because
then you're stronger you can overcome
obstacles you look at the truth you take
the bull by the horns you handle it you
overcome it whatever problems you might
experience in this world
or you can live in lies a made-up world
of which you are actually the slave
because you're controlled by a reality
that doesn't exist
the Bible says in John 8 32 and you will
know the truth and the truth will set
you free
in the second video I'm going to tell
you about something interesting about
the truth the reality of demons and
angels and my experience in it growing
up
but that will come a little bit later so
where do we find Truth where do you find
truth
absolute truth can only be found in the
one that knows truth in the one that is
truth and that is God himself and he's
been telling Humanity the truth from the
beginning of mankind and then around 40
different writers with different
professions wrote down the truth for us
in a period of a thousand five hundred
thousand six hundred years and all these
ancient writings of Truth was put
together in one book and it is called
the Bible and it is still number one for
the most sales in the world
John 17 17 says sanctify them in the
truth your word is truth
you know these people who wrote the
Bible there was a shepherdman a king a
scholar you know when you go into it
even a doctor all of these people were
so different and yet
they had the same spirit in them writing
exactly the same things over a span of
so many years a thousand five hundred
six hundred years
and nothing contradicts each other it is
so clear it is amazing and you see all
these prophecies made in the Old
Testament and all of them coming true
it's just mind-blowing even about Jesus
writing about Jesus that he will be
crucified in a time that crucifixion
didn't even exist how did they know that
and it all came true it is true because
they were Guided by The Same Spirit in
all of them
God's spirit
he wanted to tell us truth and we see
this in the New Testament clearly Jesus
said in John 16 verse 13 when the spirit
of truth comes he will guide you into
all the truth for he will not speak on
his own authority but whatever he hears
he will speak and he will declare to you
the things that are to come if you're
lost if you're trying to make sense of
the world trying to make sense of your
purpose why you are here what is your
meaning
then you need to understand that you can
only find the answers in truth itself
and God himself who created you
In His Image you are not just some
random mistake
you're created in God's image
for a purpose
and he's waiting for you to near him
with all your heart to open that door of
your heart that's
been kept shut because you didn't want
to open it
he says in Revelation 3 verse 20 behold
I stand at the door and knock if anyone
hears my voice and opens the door I will
come into him and eat with him and he
with me you know I'm telling you all of
these things because I truly care about
you
we will all die someday you might even
die soon and then where will you go
when you die
this life is not all there is
and I want you to be with me in eternal
life
man that would be so special if I can
talk to some of you guys we might not
never meet in this life but in the life
after this one
for sure
and when we're talking about these deep
truths of life I know deep inside of you
there's something that you're feeling
you might even feel uncomfortable not
sure how to react before you just
dismiss it or you you reject it or you
try to say ah I wanna watch something
else or do something else
wait hold on a second and hear me out
find out if I am speaking the truth or
not
because if I am if I'm right the
consequences are huge and it will change
your life forever
not just this short temporary world but
eternal life this world is like a small
dot you know it's like that and it goes
by
but after that
we'll continue and continue and continue
and continue it will never never end
but the decisions that you make on this
short temporary world
will determine where you will be for all
returning
you get a house insurance just in case
your house might burn with fire but you
don't do the same for your own soul that
might burn in hell
maybe you are so focused on this short
temporary world that you never think
about it anymore
I'm asking you as your friend to some of
you I'm an older brother
to others maybe even like a son and I'm
asking you really seriously I mean when
in entertainment when you watch YouTube
and movies and series when do you find
people who are truly just transparent
and open
seriously talking to one another and I'm
asking you seriously to give me a chance
give this series
a chance
I'm gonna share deep truths with you in
this series that I personally know to be
true and that I experienced in the next
video we're going to look at demon
possession
the reality of Satanism demons and the
spiritual world
how do I know it's true because I grew
up with it I'm going to share it with
you in the next video
[Music]
let me show you some footage as well
things that I've never shared on this
channel before
it's going to be very interesting and
shocking you don't want to miss that
video if you truly are searching for
truth I'll see you there
before you go always remember life is
short
so don't waste yours
cheers guys